Here's a morning in my life as a blue collar Chadwick.
My husband went to work super early this morning for a meeting,
and so I didn't get up with him
because he has been getting over pneumonia recently
and did not have an appetite for me to make him breakfast.
It's been really rainy here for the last week or so,
so I'm ready for some sunshine.
Plus, I would really like to get my garden taken care of for fall,
but I do really love the cold that it is bringing with it.
Make a hot cup of coffee, and then I get dressed for the day.
I really wanted to share this dress with you guys.
It is from the Skirt Lady boutique.
Not only is it modest and really comfortable,
but this is customizable. So I got short sleeves in a midi length.
It has pockets, and it's nursing friendly.
Our mornings are spent doing cataclysm
and just cuddling and hanging out.
Sometimes I'll have structured activities for her,
but today we just didn't.
I also usually do red light therapy and read a little bit.
I'm currently working through holiness by JC Rile.
And then it's time to get to work doing my morning chores.
When I put the apron on, it is serious.
First off, I have so much laundry to do from having house guests.
It's just kind of been backed up.
I haven't really been keeping up with it.
I also recently Thrifted a lot of fun blankets,
so I've been washing those over the weekend.
I did end up buying half a bushel that I then processed into cider.
I am now making apple crisp because I'm out of canning jars,
and I do not have the budget at the moment
to go and buy more canning jars.
So these are just gonna go into our deep freezer.
This whole process took me straight up to lunch,
and then my morning for the day was done.